[Música]
tiempo para la economía ya en France 24
para ello contamos una vez más con
nuestra compañera Daniela Blandón de
Daniela bienvenida Muchas gracias
Rodrigo y vamos a empezar hablando en
este espacio económico sobre Amazon
porque sorprendió con resultados
financieros del primer trimestre pues
sus acciones subieron casi un 5% después
de informar que sus ventas trimestrales
y sus ganancias superaron las
expectativas de Wall Street la compañía
dijo que confía en que su negocio en la
nube y en que los recortes de gastos
pues estén dando sus frutos en efecto
desde noviembre pasado anunciado la
eliminación de al menos 27.000 puestos
de trabajo el más reciente recorte lo
hizo en sus lucrativos negocios de
información en la nube y de publicidad
ya con todos estos despidos queda con
uno coma 47 millones de trabajadores
ahora miremos las cifras en los tres
primeros meses del año sus ingresos
subieron casi un 10% mientras que en
términos de utilidades generó números
ver después de que el año pasado hubiera
reportado su primera pérdida trimestral
en años Bueno pero Daniela otras
tecnológicas también han revelado sus
resultados pues este informe de Amazon
lo que hace es completar una ajetreada
semana en las que hemos visto ganancias
para las principales empresas
tecnológicas por ejemplo la matriz de
Facebook Meta superó las expectativas de
ganancias e ingresos y sus acciones
subieron hoy un 14%. Microsoft subió
también sus utilidades gracias a un
segmento de información en la nube más
creciente cada vez este mismo segmento
aumentó un 28% en el caso de Google
vamos a seguir hablando de tecnología
Daniela porque Europa Busca ahora
regular la industria de la Inteligencia
artificial Pues un comité de
legisladores llegó este jueves a un
acuerdo preliminar sobre lo que se ha
conocido como ley Europea de
Inteligencia artificial que allanaría el
camino hacia las primeras leyes
integrales del mundo que rijan esta
tecnología entre otras cosas se busca
que herramientas de Inteligencia
artificial se clasifiquen según su nivel
de riesgo para los usuarios Es decir
desde mínimo riesgo hasta limitado alto
e inaceptable las áreas de preocupación
podrían incluir la vigilancia biométrica
o la difusión de información errónea o
inclusive el lenguaje discriminatorio
los miembros del parlamento europeo
acordaron llevar este borrador a la
siguiente etapa que es un diálogo
tripartito allá en el seno del
legislativo interesante Daniela porque
es un tema que preocupa en Europa
recordemos que ya Italia prohibió la
inteligencia del chat gpt por temas de
protección de datos vamos ahora hasta
Estados Unidos porque hay un nuevo
pronunciamiento de La Casa Blanca sobre
las relaciones con china que han dicho
pues que Washington no busca romper las
relaciones económicas con china según lo
dijo Jake Sullivan el asesor de
seguridad nacional En una conferencia
sobre políticas públicas esto Dijo
estamos a favor de reducir y
diversificar no desvincularnos
Seguiremos invirtiendo en nuestras
propias capacidades y en cadenas de
suministro seguras y resilientes nuestra
restricciones en importaciones seguirán
concentradas en tecnología solo nos
estamos asegurando de que esta
tecnología no sea usada en contra de
nosotros
lo más llamativo de estos comentarios es
que llegan Un día después de que la
secretaria de comercio de ese mismo país
tiene Raymundo dijera ayer miércoles que
las empresas chinas de computación en la
nube como Huawei Cloud y alibaba Cloud
podrían representar una amenaza para la
seguridad de Estados Unidos a su vez
ella se comprometió a revisar una
solicitud que hicieron los legisladores
republicanos para agregarlas a una lista
de control de exportaciones y todas
Ascensión se suma por supuesto a la que
ya existe por el supuesto riesgo que
también representaría tiktok para los
usuarios de este país
Dani vamos con Los habituales
indicadores de las bolsas del mundo
positivo y el dow Jones de industriales
que es su principal indicador subió
1,58% en su mejor día en tres meses esto
después de que el crecimiento económico
de Estados Unidos se desacelerará más de
lo esperado en el primer trimestre en
efecto el producto interno bruto aumentó
a una tasa anual del 1,1% el trimestre
pasado sí está creciendo pero en el
cuarto trimestre había crecido a un
ritmo del 2,6%. las acciones europeas
terminaron al alza en su mayoría
respaldadas por ganancias positivas
Especialmente del Dodge banca y de
barclays que aliviaron las
preocupaciones sobre la salud del sector
bancario y en América Latina la Bolsa
Mexicana tuvo su primer avance después
de dos sesiones consecutivas con
pérdidas
del día bueno yo no creo que sea tan
buena para muchos iguales buena para
unos y mala para otros y son los 4.6
pesos colombianos que cuesta hoy un
dólar la moneda local registró una
pronunciada devaluación frente a la
divisa estadounidense de más de 100
pesos en un solo día después de los
repentinos cambios en el gabinete
incluido el ministro de hacienda José
Antonio Ocampo a propósito de Colombia
el país aprobó el examen del fondo
monetario internacional la entidad
multilateral dijo que reúne los
requisitos para acceder a una línea de
crédito flexible para tu bolsillo para
el mío creo que no es una buena cifra
Muchas gracias por este repaso económico
nos vemos mañana mañana nos vemos acá
con mucho más Muchas gracias vamos a la
pausa y ya seguimos con directo a
América